maman reprend le travail cette semaine
on a parlé a pas que tu t'en ailles
reste là
[Musique]
dessus tout
tadam
c'est pour tes trophée de golf c'est
pour toi
tu imagines un film direct en bouquin je
suis stressée je peux pas m'empêcher 1
profite à fond je me demande seulement
pourquoi vous ne répondait à aucune de
mes questions vous ne dites rien
il ya des tas de photos qui manque les
est moche pourquoi
je me suis mariée sans savoir dans quoi
je m'engageais tu pourrais leur apporter
pour quelles raisons vous rapportez
votre mari par où commencer
[Musique]
au
couteau
fantômes
c'est trop triste parce que tu es canon
tu sais
quand on veut se venger comme un homme
on s'habille comme un art où on peut
renoncer à se venger et une pseudo
j'ai fait une rencontre
non tu veux
je te mettrai ont vite moi même un gros
risque que tu viens de prendre pour un
métis touahri soir
je ne suis vraiment pas comment les
femmes réussissent ce tour là on est un
peu sorcière
si chantôme alors pourquoi ces craintes
continuent à faire chier